le vice-président économiste en chef et
stratège du Mouvement Desjardins a
présenté aujourd'hui une mise à jour de
ses prévisions économiques Jimmy Jean
est avec nous pour faire le point
aujourd'hui bonjour Monsieur Jean alors
il y a environ un mois vous étiez sur ce
plateau et déjà vous nous annoncez une
récession pour l'an prochain qu'est-ce
qui a changé exactement dans vos
prévisions en fait il y a un mois on
avait la compétition que le Canada pour
le Canada le scénario le plus probable
était celui d'une récession maintenant
ce qu'on dit c'est qu'on devrait
connaître une récession mondiale l'an
prochain parce que on a maintenant
statut que pour les États-Unis également
le scénario le plus probable et celui
d'une récession or 4 des 5 dernières
récession mondiales ont mis en vedette
une récession aux États-Unis donc les
États-Unis c'est très influent et si les
États-Unis sont en récession en général
la planète les
oui parce que on le dit ici au Canada en
plus on est très lié aux États-Unis donc
j'imagine qu'il y aura des répercussions
pour l'économie canadienne à travers le
canal des exportations notamment mais je
pense dans tous les cas ce qu'on peut
dire c'est que les taux d'intérêt
montent de manière très agressive et
partout au monde donc essayer le cas ici
au Canada on s'attend à ce que la fin
approche pour les hausses de tout mais
même si la Banque du Canada devait CSS
et hausse de tout après la prochaine
rencontre d'octobre il reste que les
autres banques centrales restent de
pousser les autos beaucoup plus haut et
on n'est pas sur une île déserte donc
les effets l'effet des relations très
fortes sur les marchés financiers fait
en sorte que on risque d'importer
l'effet de resserrement qui se fait
ailleurs même si la Banque du Canada a
arrêté vous attendez donc à ce que la
Banque du Canada met un peu la
sur les hausses de taux directeur c'est
ce que je voyais dans votre rapport là
qu'est-ce que vous prévoyez pour les
prochaines annonces donc en ce moment on
est à trois et quart on s'attend à se
rendre à 3 et 3/4 donc 3,75% à la
Réunion d'octobre à partir de ce
moment-là je pense que la Banque du
Canada va avoir certains arguments pour
pouvoir dire que elle a fait le
nécessaire entre autres avec ce qu'on
prévoit pour l'inflation l'année
prochaine ça va vous leur dire que les
taux réels donc les taux ajustés pour
l'inflation vont être redevenues en
territoire positif donc ça c'est un
jalon important en matière de
crédibilité l'autre chose aussi c'est
que plus on augmente les taux plus ça
fait mal pour plusieurs emprunteurs qui
certains qui devront payer plus sur leur
paiement hypothécaire à taux variable
dès maintenant effectivement donc ça
c'est un enjeu et je pense pas que la
Banque du Canada veut provoquer une
crise financière on veut ralentir la
demande mais il faut faire attention
pour pas pousser la note ce qui pourrait
mettre des gens en situation de
difficulté je pense pas que la vente du
Canada veut nécessairement ce scénario
là parce qu'on savoir un certain
ralentissement de l'inflation le marché
immobilier aussi qui commence à se
calmer mais selon vous les hausses de
taux des derniers mois pourraient
continuer à avoir un effet encore sur
une plus longue période donc pas
nécessairement besoin d'en ajouter c'est
un peu ça tout à fait les travaux
empiriques sont très clairs là-dessus le
premier effet on l'observe sur le marché
mobilier sur les ventes immobilières
c'est exactement ce qu'on voit on est à
15 % de baisse au niveau des prix depuis
le mois de février au Canada on s'attend
ce que ça se poursuive par contre il y a
des effets qui vont continuer on a parlé
de construction de rénovation ça ça va
se poursuivre et en général les phases
sur la consommation a tendance à
survenir plusieurs trimestres par la
suite donc ces effets-là on les a pas
encore tout à fait sentis mais ils sont
à venir et en 2023 c'est pour ça qu'on
pense que ça va malheureusement causer
une contraction mais on pense que c'est
une contraction qui va être quand même
assez légère qui va être de courte durée
et au Québec est-ce que ça ça se passera
pareil comme pour l'ensemble mettre du
Canada où on se rend un peu protégés
comme on l'a été récemment les données
sont plus fortes au Québec je pense
qu'il va falloir reconnaître que le
Québec malheureusement n'est pas sur une
île déserte donc on va subir les faits
si l'Ontario est en récession sur les
États-Unis le sont également on risque
d'avoir une période de plus difficile
par contre pour le Québec un des points
de résilience c'est vraiment le taux
d'épargne et on se compare nettement
avant tout jugement par rapport au reste
du Canada à ce niveau là les Québécois
ont accumulé beaucoup de liquidités
pendant la crise donc ça va faire en
sorte qu'ils vont être capables de
passer à travers de meilleure façon et
ça va prévenir aussi les insolvabilités
les problèmes financiers donc je pense
que à ce niveau là on est assez
encouragé l'autre chose c'est les
pénuries de main d'oeuvre qui font en
sorte que il y a plusieurs employeurs
qui vont peut-être hésiter à mettre à
licencier des employés et la minute on
va avoir un certain reprise les
employeurs vont peut-être se dépêcher
aussi à réembaucher étant donné qu'on
connaît les difficultés la longueur que
ça peut prendre pour embaucher d'un
employé qualifié donc pour que ça risque
de faire en sorte que l'augmentation du
taux de chômage va être plus bas ce
qu'on a vu dans les derniers cycles et
on risque de voir le tout chômage
diminué de nouveau dans la reprise de
manière plus rapide j'aimerais
rapidement vous entendre les plans
d'aide pour lutter contre l'inflation au
Royaume-Uni ça a été très mal accueilli
est-ce qu'on doit tirer des leçons de ça
ici au Canada tout à fait donc c'est un
message vibrant qu'on voit sur les
marchés financiers quand à la
c'est important pour les gouvernements
de pas exagérer avec ce genre de mesure
là on a décrété un programme très musclé
correspondant 1% du PIB ici ce qu'on a
fait au niveau fédéral ça correspond à
peu près à 0,1% du PIB donc ça change
pas la donne on a fixé on a un focus
vraiment sur les ménages les plus
vulnérables mais la borne a décrété des
baisses d'impôts très agressives
politiques monétaire politique
budgétaire expansionniste dans un
contexte inflationniste c'est pas une
bonne idée merci beaucoup Monsieur Jean
toujours très éclairant merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]